in this video we'll talk about
allergic rhinitis
let's break the term
rhine means nose and itis means
inflammation
so if we think about it simply it means
inflammation of the nose due to an
allergy
now it is often characterized by runny
nose
there are many key features of this
disease
so first of all the nose get irritated
by some kind of allergen such as pollen
grain dust or pollutants
that leads to a runny nose itching
sensation around the nose and reddening
of the nose
and sneezing is a most common symptom
in most of the cases it is highly
treatable with
medicines which are
available over the counter
now let's talk about the symptoms of
allergic rhinitis in bit more
so the symptoms include sneezing
itchy nose
runny and blocked nose
itchy and red sensation around the eyes
and nose area
cough and overall itchy feeling on the
roof of the mouth
all of these things are kind of very
peculiar to allergic rhinitis and these
are similar to a common cold
one thing to be noticed is
the
the fluid that comes out from the nose
is actually totally clear
now the key cause of these allergic
rhinitis is the pollen grains from
several flowers and trees and this is
kind of seasonal
the other
causative
agents are like
dust
world spores dust mites animal hair etc
now let's try to understand the
immunology behind this allergic response
so
in simple terms allergic rhinitis is one
kind of allergy
from a medical point of view this is
known as type 1 hypersensitivity
reaction or allergic reaction so now
let's zoom into the nasal mucosa so
these are epithelial cells and
you can see the thick layer of mucus on
top of it so when there is an allergen
such as some pollen grains enter our
system there are dendritic cells or
antigen presenting cells which can
engulf these
pollen grains and display those antigens
on the top of mhc class 2 molecules
this might lead to activation of t cells
and indeed t cell secretes several
cytokines which are pro-inflammatory in
nature
this leads to a reddening and a itchy
sensation in the nose area
further the t cell can activate b cell
and b cell can get converted into a ige
secreting plasma cell
now ige antibodies are the key agent in
this allergic response
ige antibody can bind to the surface of
mast cell
and this is called a sensitization phase
now these mass cells are becoming
sensitized when there is a second
exposure to these allergy maybe in a
season there are multiple exposure to
this allergen
so in the second exposure
the
mast cell would degranulate and this
would secrete several
chemokines in its surrounding one such
chemokine is actually histamine
now histamine can lead to vasodilation
that means
dilation of the capillaries
now the vasodilation leads to
extravasation or movement of several
immune cells into the inflamed area such
as this neutrophil shown in this diagram
also it can lead to fluid leakage in
this area that leads to that
excessive amount of fluid which comes
out of the nose or eyes
now overall the nasal mucosa is highly
inflamed
and in general
here the nasal mucosa there are a lot of
mast cells
and all of these muscles degranulate
make the capillaries around the nose
highly permeable that leads to a lot of
a lot of like runny sensation in the
nose that leads to excess fluid and we
can see it watering of the eyes or
watering of the nose
now let's talk about the treatment
options of allergic rhinitis
so as we have discussed so far the key
causative
feature of these allergic rhinitis is
the histamine so obviously one can use
antihistamines to treat allergy rhinitis
there are bunch of medicines available
under the category of antihistamines
which can treat the symptoms
other than that the nasal congestion is
a problem during this allergic rhinitis
and the nose can be decongested using
specific nasal sprays or nasal drops
which would constrict the basic
blood vessels and that would reduce the
overall congestion and the runny nose
kind of same things
but it is not recommended for children
under six years of age
other hygienic treatments such as salt
water wash off the nasal mucosa would
give you a temporary relief
now question is how long does it last
so it can last about one week but with
treatment things can get better within a
week in some rare occasions thing might
persist more than a week but it is
extremely near so this video overall
summarizes the features of allergic
dynamities that cause and the possible
treatments
you can go get many notes and flashcards
in my facebook page and instagram as
well all the links are provided in the
description don't forget to check them
out
you can support my channel in patreon
also if you are an indian viewer you can
either pay using this qr code
via any kind of upi app or you can pay
via super tanks which is present in the
product side of the video
anyway if you want to connect to me you
can use all these social media links all
are provided in the description box as
usual don't forget to like